la grosse différence entre les
socialistes et nous sur la vision de
l'agriculteur de l'agriculture c'est que
les socialistes considèrent les
agriculteurs comme des fonctionnaires
avec des aides
nous on considère les agriculteurs comme
de véritables chefs d'entreprise et tu
l'as bien résumé l'agriculture c'est un
pan entier de notre économie française
et je crois que vraiment on doit aller
dans ce sens là pour les aider plus
fortement autre sujet délicat difficile
sur lequel on doit travailler c'est
l'énorme la sueur transposition des
normes qui pénalise fortement notre
agriculture notamment au niveau de la
compétitivité mode nino un petit peu
comment tu vois les choses ton avis là
dessus et surtout comment on peut éviter
à chaque fois de charge et de charges et
de charger la barque pour nos
agriculteurs
bonjour à tous à l'heure aussi je suis
ici c'est évidemment pour vous parler un
petit peu aussi d'écologie et vous
expliquer combien l'écologie peut aller
avec l'agriculture et qu'il faut arrêter
de les opposer
mon combat il date depuis près de 15 ans
évidemment on est tous d'accord on peut
tous une planète en bonne santé pour nos
enfants
je pense que les agriculteurs qui sont à
mes côtés que je connais bien sont tout
à fait de cet avis là où moi je me
distingue peut-être du discours un peu
alarmiste et culpabilisateur qu'on a
tendance à trop souvent entendre c'est
que je pense que cette préservation de
l'environnement ne va pas en opposition
avec le fait que nos agriculteurs vivent
dignement de leur profession alors
aujourd'hui il est certain que
l'agriculture d'il ya 20 ans n'est plus
d'actualité
les agriculteurs et moi je le vois pour
les rencontrer pour aller sur le terrain
sont les premiers à faire évoluer la
profession que ça soit on en a parlé sur
la qualité des produits que ce soit sur
le bien-être animal que ça soit sur
l'autonomie énergétique des bâtiments
que ce soit sur la la le le bien-être au
travail que ça soit sur tous les
bienfaits que nous apportent
l'agriculture aujourd'hui il ya une
constante amélioration et notamment de
précisions sur tout ce qui concerne les
traitements et les innovations
aujourd'hui j'ose le dire je pense que
les agriculteurs sont les premiers
écologistes alors ça fait grincer
non mais je le pense sincèrement je le
pense parce que même si ça fait grincer
les dents de nos amis écolos je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les agriculteurs au delà
de nous nourrir
c'est quand même fondamental ce sont eux
qui entretiennent notre patrimoine
naturel
nos paysages nos campagnes et que serait
la france celle que nous aimons sens
justement ce patrimoine naturel
l'homme en tout temps à toujours
transformer en quelque sorte construit
la nature les agriculteurs sont les
premiers coproducteur de la biodiversité
et ce sont les premiers à travailler la
main dans la main avec les scientifiques
parce que les agriculteurs connaissent
le terrain sont qui eux c'est comme ces
marins que je défends souvent et ses
pêcheurs qui connaissent le milieu et
qui peuvent en suivre rendre compte
eh bien c'est la même chose avec nos
agriculteurs et c'est sur eux que dépend
la qualité de nos zoo et la qualité des
écosystèmes que ça soit forestier ou de
l'eau différents d'écosystèmes dont on a
besoin
aujourd'hui le problème c'est qu'il ya
quand même une certaine incohérence de
vouloir sans cesse produire plus
produire mieux produire moins cher et
être complètement asphyxiée par une
quantité de normes et de réglementations
complètement débordante
on veut laver plus blanc que blanc en
france et on va sur transposer ces
normes européennes jusqu'à demander
l'impossible à nos agriculteurs
ce qui malheureusement aujourd'hui n'est
malheureusement plus vivable en france
on a tendance à dire on n'a pas de
pétrole mais on a des idées
enfin j'étais ans on a je crois qu'on
oublie un peu quand on justement on
légifère un peu à tour de bras on va
appliquer ce principe de précaution qui
certes peut nous rassurer mais qui
devrait peut-être évolué en un principe
d'innovation un principe de
responsabilité on bride la recherche et
on asphyxie complètement et on va vers
un discours qui est sans cesse porté sur
l'apocalypse se sert plus vendeur mais
qui n'est pas du tout dans les réalités
ce que vivent nos agriculteurs que
faut-il qu'on fait c'est ce que nous
allons faire au sein des républicains
c'est soutenir cette profession lui la
soutenir c'est déjà lui faire confiance
dans cette volonté là dans cette volonté
d'ailleurs
je tiens à le préciser de limiter les
pesticides parce que des agriculteurs
sont pas les premiers amoureux des
pesticides contrairement à ce qu'on peut
en dire
premièrement ça leur coûte cher et
deuxièmement ils sont aussi conscients
que nous de la terre qui veulent laisser
à nos enfants
donc les soutenir valoriser le travail
qu'ils font sur cette valorisation du
des écosystèmes il va bien falloir
penser à ça et aujourd'hui les les
décisions précis qui va leur comprennent
c'est un moratoire sur l'assurance
position des lois européennes s'est
associé les agriculteurs donc les
professionnels au travail réglementaire
au travail législatif
et c'est peut-être également dé
construire une certes un certain nombre
de normes qui aujourd'hui sont devenus
complètement obsolète parfois même
incohérente
il faut revoir ça avec les
professionnels les impliquer
complètement dans le processus au sein
du ministère de l'agriculture est une
nouvelle fois arrêter d'opposer
agriculture et écologie
j'en suis persuadé dans mon combat on
peut être pêcheur sans être pilleurs ont
peut être armateurs sans forcément faire
de marée noire on peut être industriels
s'en est obnubilé par le greenwashing et
on peut être agriculteur et penser à
cette préservation de l'environnement et
ça ira en assurant l'innovation
technique technologique et en
investissant sur la recherche est donc
surtout ce qui est in ovation pour faire
évoluer cette profession dans les années
futures
donc je vous soutiens bien très bien
même